will smith quits in a preemptive move
the actor released a statement saying he
was resigning from the academy of motion
pictures arts and sciences calling his
actions shocking painful and inexcusable
the oscar winner said he'll accept any
punishment handed out by the board of
governors when they meet again on april
18th the academy put out their own
statement saying they've accepted his
resignation but disciplinary proceedings
will go forward what does this all mean
he now won't receive screeners for films
or get to vote for potential oscar
nominees and it will be up to the board
to decide if he can be nominated again
or attend future academy award
ceremonies as for his oscar it's
unlikely he'll have to return it both
harvey weinstein and roman polenski were
ejected from the academy for their
scandals but neither were forced to give
back their oscars meanwhile the fallout
continues for will netflix has
reportedly put a pause on his movie fast
and loose while sony has halted
pre-production on bad boys 4. of course
the slap scene around the world was
still the talk of the grammys we're
going to be dancing we're going to be
singing we're going to be keeping
people's names out of our mouths and
we're going to be giving out awards
all throughout the night and of course
ethanol took a shot at the incident in a
sketch with host gerard carmichael
i'll be right back
hey so where you from man